shawna Gary most big successes have a
huge turning point where things really
take on what was that turning point for
wine library Shawn great question you
know I guess there was some turning
points when you know the wine spectator
add that we ran the first New York Times
full-page ad the time I reset the store
and took fifty percent of the beer off
the floor and added more wine when I
started Wine Library com the day I
started the email service the dot the
dad jumped into Robert Parker's forums
in 97 and became part of the internet
community around wine you know the two
thousand Bordeaux vintage when we bought
heavy when I first started promoting
wines of the nobody ever heard of an
email Richard partridge Cabernet comes
to mind when I hired Brandon as you can
tell there are many moments that we made
it but it was just trucking along
building on top of each other step by
step my friends if you listen to two of
my answers on this show you understand
one very interesting thing about me
which is I may have the energy of the
hair but I am The Tortoise you know what
I'm putting up there right that
beautiful thing you did sack show Zach
did a very nice job on that one ah for
everybody listening I'm pointing to the
tortoise and hare image I put out an
Instagram go check me out on Instagram /
Gary Vee anyway ah but when I made it
the turning point moment everybody who's
watching and asking these questions are
looking for this sign like I saw the
sign like like this sign that like okay
it's not that its head down you love and
believe in what you do and you just
never think about those moments you just
keep trucking along it's lunch pail
mentality it's old-school Eastern
European put in the work mentality you
know I don't think about these things
guys the fortune 40 under 40 that just
happened is that a turning point in my
career sure some people now think of me
differently because I'm in the context
of those people but it's not it's just
chug and chug and chug and chug and chug
and chug and chug and chug and so chug
oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe